en diciembre de 2017 irak declaró sus
victorias sobre el grupo estado islámico
los yihadistas habían llegado a
controlar 40% del territorio del país
bajo un autodenominado califato que
también comprendía gran parte de siria
allí dos años después también fueron
derrotados el grupo estado islámico
perdió todo su control territorial pero
nunca desapareció del todo
sigue vivo en irak y opera con pequeñas
células responsables de decenas de
atentados en todo el país sobre todo son
ataques relámpagos contra
infraestructuras y objetivos civiles sus
fuerzas están diezmadas aunque su
intención es volver a reagruparse
pero no sólo sigue vivo en irak cuando
el poder del grupo estado islámico
empezó a disminuir en su llamado
califato los líderes yihadistas pidieron
a sus seguidores que permanecieran en
sus países de origen e hicieran crecer
el grupo terrorista allí
desde entonces el poder del estado
islámico en regiones de áfrica y de asia
no ha dejado de aumentar de hecho son
grupos cada vez más autónomos de los
líderes centrales de irak uno de los
ejemplos más claros es afganistán donde
el grupo yihadista tampoco ostenta
control territorial pero es capaz de
lanzar atentados contra el mismo
ejército de eeuu
un reporte del consejo de seguridad de
la onu asegura que el grupo terrorista
todavía tiene entre 25 y 50 millones de
dólares y cree que la mayoría del dinero
sigue en irak desde donde se distribuye
a sus filiales en otros países es por
eso que irak sigue siendo clave en la
lucha internacional contra el terrorismo
eeuu todavía mantiene allí 2500 tropas
aunque el presidente bailén anunció que
a finales de año terminarán todas sus
misiones de combate en el país y solo
seguirán entrenando el ejército iraquí
para que continúen luchando contra los
yihadistas
el mismo objetivo que tenía eeuu en
afganistán